current climate change pledges from
world leaders will not be enough to keep
global temperature targets according to
a new report from the united nations the
organization's secretary general has
warned world leaders that the era of
promises must end saying closing the
emissions gap must start in glasgow as
world leaders come under even more
pressure just a few days before cop 26
can the summit be a success
vicky it has been described as a
thundering wake up call today that the
world is heading towards climate
catastrophe will world leaders pay
attention ahead of that summit
well they will and i think we've been
prepared for it i mean obviously there
was some hint that the the report was
going to suggest pretty bad news in
terms of what has been achieved so far
and what the various pledges will be
achieving
and of course it's a wake-up call and
boris johnson himself has been telling
everyone not to expect perhaps too much
because that gap is enormous in the
sense of what needs to be done extra if
we are to get even near
achieving uh the 1.5 it looks like on
current projections if we believe the
the figures are coming out now that
we're going to be way above that and
what needs to happen is that efforts
should be concentrated very much on what
goes on between now and 2030 and what i
find quite surprising actually
is that despite the fact that both the
uk of course and the eu seem to have
quite ambitious plans that they have put
together which will be reducing uh
carbon emissions very significantly from
1990 levels um with the eu of course
pledging 55 percent the uk pushing even
higher figures by 2030 to 2035 um
obviously the big emitters the us china
and of course up to the point also india
don't look like they're doing enough i'm
guessing that is why it looks so bad in
terms of what the pledges are telling us
simon the warning came that if there's
no meaningful change we will have lost
forever the chance of achieving 1.5
celsius and only 2.7 degree rises in
temperatures this century in practical
terms what would that mean what would it
look like
it's a world we really don't want to
find out about
large areas of the earth would have
unlivable heat
at
parts of the year um we would see the
kind of climb impacts we saw last summer
of massive heat waves in canada
of floods washing houses into
the
rivers in germany and people up to their
necks in
water on the subway system in china
happening with great frequency and
for me i think it's very hard to see how
agriculture globally can adapt to that
kind of level
of change uh and keep food supplies
going for what will at that point be uh
eight or nine billion people on earth it
would be a real catastrophe and world
leaders um
in in these next two weeks really need
to um
push hard to have practical policies to
reduce emissions in the short term and
simon we heard that warning from the
prime minister yesterday that that he's
really worried we've had saudi arabia's
pledges we've had australia today but
the problem has been highlighted that
many of those net zero goals remain
vague we haven't got the details of them
and much of the heavy lifting is pushed
to after
2030
is anything in glasgow going to change
that
well i do think that these net zero
pledges are important because they bring
climate action
two decades earlier and that means that
we then start talking about what is
going to happen in the 2020s and what to
watch out for at this summit is the
first two days when more than 120 world
leaders will be in glasgow making
pledges and making announcements and
that's the time to look for potentially
big announcements about what might
happen over the next decade
you